c49b5 is
on the board ladies and gentlemen
jordan is getting closer and closer
to a win
jordan is just playing marvelous chess
he's lost zero games so he's not taking
[Music]
risk
jordan fun forest with impressive
amazing performance
amazing games wins the last
round we are in for a tie breaks people
we have
tie break between two dutchmen aneesh
giri and jordan fun for race
[Music]
oh my we have the winner of the
tournament that it is jordan fanfares
winning the dramatic armageddon
basically it comes down to a lot of luck
so i don't know he played the better
chess
maybe i played the faster chess in the
end and full credit to him he played a
really good tournament and he
really deserved to win it i mean he was
could have won both of his last games
too i think
but yeah this is just how it goes and
how do you feel
yeah just on top of the road i think so
a lot of feelings um but going through
my head
but i think it still has to you know
still in a bit come hit me you know and
i think that comes when all the
interviews and
and stuff is done and when i'm like at
night in my bed trying to sleep
something like this